unfortunately japan is losing a lot of
its old kind of historic buildings
harajuku station the nakagin capsule
building is going next year
um the cool sega building an arcade in
akihabara yeah they've got a very
utilitarian mindset here and conor's
choking to death
right now he's gone time to take over
his channel
but like yeah they've got a very
utilitarian mindset as long as it gets
the job done that's the main thing
and if you go to someone like tokyo
station all the skyscrapers look the
same
they're all kind of i mean yeah that
part of japan is or tokyo is quite
bland and grey and you can go to any
town across japan it looks
more or less the same you'll have the
same things there's no it's rare to find
good historic architecture
i mean i don't think it's about the
historic architecture no i don't like
that though i like i like that
it is it is cool like the historical
architecture in japan is cool but i
think as well like
i think like the aesthetic that a lot of
people love about japan is like kind of
the
the alleyway in the back alley i mean i
love that
yeah the golden guy looks like that's
[ __ ] amazing area yeah but everywhere
else is just so depressing it all just
looks like a mess
i kind of i kind of think london is like
that most of it if it's not if it's not
zone one or zone two
then what have what have we got really
it looks really good i think all the
buildings that are like i don't know i
really like the look it's really
nice very well designed because you
lived in morden
i was like what's there in morden
because i i lived in strengthening
strathmore
it sounds a lot cooler than it looks
like we're going to morden
it looks pretty nice i like that nobody
enters morden i do remember
when i went back to the uk for the first
time in two and a half years i remember
looking up and going okay the uk's
architecture is pretty good the old
brick buildings and whatnot
you know in central london but uh yeah
in central london yeah
all the customers chris hates landings
he's english oh well sorry
yeah yeah yeah tom jones right angles
i see on holiday in anglesey north wales
why
went canoeing oh kayaking good
englishman come to our land
take advantage of our
yeah you showed me around sendai he's
like look it's just a big apartment
building in the middle of like
this like no i'll take you to an 80s bar
yeah yeah i was getting
it is that the one you took me to i
think so right probably
yeah no 60s bar oh the 60s we were
driving to the ski resort right because
it's like look there's just a big
apartment building
in between all these [ __ ] normal
houses yeah it's like weird thing where
like
it just looks so out of place it was
like some kind of lord of the rings
apartment building
it's true like yeah in yamagata
prefecture there's just a rice field and
some planes a few huts
and then there's like 150 foot buildings
it's like
it's like a shower
had loads of money and was friends with
like the governor of yamagata apparently
he's like yeah i want to build a tall
building you know get people coming he
was like i could make it happen
they did it i think it was a failure and
then the tallest building
is like just in a field quick just it's
ridiculous
fields and then just a massive [ __ ] off
flashlight it's really quite distinctive
it sounds like a little cool it's kind
of cool it's cool but
i think it's cool yeah but normally the
reason the reason why you pack
people so dense like that is because
they're close to something of value
like something you know like a station
or one right that's the reason why that
works not because there's rice fields
it's like yeah like kowloon wall city
what if all the rice farmers want to
live
like close to each other farmers need
land for their tools and she can't bring
it back into his condo apartment his
[ __ ] tractor
where's he gonna put it but i feel like
that that's part of the charm of japan
right because it feels like there are no
rules
and you know you can find the most
random places or random things in the
most random places
there's no rules in the most
bureaucratic country in existence
definitely in terms of architecture like
japan i feel has no rules
yeah in [ __ ] japan and
that's like what other countries out
there being like you know what we need a
town based around wales i mean
even [ __ ] england doesn't do that and
yeah it was still better than wales
22 [ __ ] dollars for fish and chips
you'd be surprised we've talked about
that podcast before yeah